yeah it was my first time ever driving
on the side of the road same but it's
weird how quickly you kind of how easy
it is to adapt yeah I thought I thought
I was going to struggle because it's
going again against every driving
Instinct that I have like it's already
weird sitting on the other side of the
car so yeah Japan UK Australia all drive
on the uh left side left yeah and
America obviously they're right from the
right and most of Europe actually drives
yeah as well but uh yeah it is weird how
quickly your brain I noticed that when I
was driving when I was following cars it
was super easy but as I was coming to a
junction if it was just me I would have
that brief moment of like oh yeah
turn wise yeah yeah yeah it's wide when
turning left I had that a few times when
I was first on the vest but like we'd
come to like a teens section if there's
no other cars I would kind of yeah I'd
have to be like that way yeah and I'd
want to turn left and I almost [__]
one time I almost went into oncomes
oh
[__] terrifying luckily there's
always cars parked places yes sure help
you figure it out like yeah you'd be
surprised it's pretty easy I think in
Europe with roundabouts it'd definitely
be a lot more uh tricky yeah yeah a lot
more intimidating yeah um especially if
you're doing like manual as well I don't
know
I think if you feel confident driving
generally I think it's fine yeah but if
you're not a confident driver in general
I think it's a little harder it's a
little scarier yeah I don't know if this
is a hot take but
I think that now now that I've you know
gone back to Thailand for a month and
just remind and just reconfigured my
mind
I think it's easier to drive in
Southeast Asia than it is to drive on
like like Western roads like America and
England
uh I I honestly I okay I think it's like
it's like the equivalent of saying like
it's easier to drink a cup noodle by
just Downing it you know what I mean
like it's like what because like because
when all rules go out the window hell
yeah it's easy to [__] drive because
you just [__] show up yeah like you
don't need to worry about the lights and
where people are just just do it I mean
that's the thing right because I I kind
of realized this because uh you know
I've lived I've lived in Thailand for
about like four years uh before you know
before moving to Japan so I have a lot
of driving experience in Thailand and
yes like the first like day or two that
you like drive there especially when I
came back this time I was like oh the
roads are [__] terrifying and then
when you get used to it you kind of like
you feel like every driver just enters a
kind of Flow State and that that's gonna
that's that's what it feels like it
feels like the traffic just has its own
flow that you you kind of like get a
feel about when you can go when
someone's gonna stop it's it's I'm
listening I'm sure to Google something
really I because when we were in
Thailand and I was sitting on the back
of those cabs I I I felt nothing like
that at all there were so many like
there were moments where I was in the
back of this cab yeah and this so-called
flow of traffic was so [__] like
start stop stop that I was getting sick
by the end of it maybe it was a [__]
driver as well but like that's because
the driver is in Ultra Instinct and you
were still in like your baseball you
know you know you you were the side
character you're like I can't tell
what's going on right now and the drive
was just like I understand everything
I'm like I can't see anything all I see
is an incoming crash right now what's
going on but oh yeah it's because like I
realized
um because driving in Hawaii uh yeah
like trying to learn not trying to learn
but uh sometimes you're not you're
unfamiliar with the road yeah uh I was
probably the closest to getting into a
crash in Hawaii uh out of out of this
because you weren't following the rules
following the rules I thought I knew the
rules that was a green light there was a
green light I thought I could just turn
I I just Google because I was I was near
certain that like obviously the reason
why we have all these goddamn bridges
for safety yeah it is yeah and generally
yeah I think in Thailand there's a
higher death rate oh yeah of course yeah
yeah I mean like it's why we have all
these boring rules and you can't go when
you want because yeah yeah the traffic
accident yeah it but like I feel like it
definitely feels less uh
obviously it feels easier but once you
get past you know the intimidation of
everyone's doing their own thing it's
it's kind of like comforting to drive
there maybe I'm just like going back to
my bloodline like I said I think you've
just been in that situation too many
times now where it's just numbed you
because it's like it was definitely not
the case with me yeah yeah I would be
[__] [__] myself if I was Dr if I
had to drive especially if I was on a
moped in Thailand oh my God yeah we'll
we'll do a trip around Vietnam or
Thailand or something get you a few days
on a road I can survive if I could
survive that trip I can drive anywhere
yeah you know you know like I feel like
okay so you know like The Stereotype you
know uh stereotype we had before that
Asians are bad drivers you know you know
I I feel like there was some truth to
that and I feel like some of that truth
was there weren't bad drivers they just
went by the rules of their home country
which in Western countries counts very
much as a bad driver
it's gentrified Asia
they were just bringing like the a the
Asian culture to America and America's
all like what's going on here they're
bringing MMA rules to a box
British people have bad food they just
brought it from others exactly
yeah I mean like I still I like this
like the level Beyond me is I still
don't know how you know some people in
Vietnam or southeast Asia how they get
away with some of the [__] they tow or
like get on their scooters carrying
their entire family is dangerous like
yeah like four people on a scooter yeah
I saw I saw someone towing a [__]
Tree in Vietnam yes
they had this like tiny little trailer
that was obviously way too small for
this [__] tree and I'm like there is
no way that that is stable right now
we're about to get the [__] we're about
to get a tree on the [__] engine yeah
she's probably dying
ruin your [__] moment
oh my God I just feel like a lot of
common sense goes out the window
sometimes just to like she's like yeah I
can yeah and they never stop to think
should I it's like I only have this
moped but damn I need this tree though
it's three just being dragged around on
the floor no no you have that trailer
you had like a tiny ass [__] trailer
okay my head I envisioned yeah some dude
it's just attached to a moped and a tree
and it's sliding on the ground it wasn't
that much better honestly the trailer
did the trailer looked like it was like
doing nothing every time they just sweep
out yeah
how the [__] did they hook up a trailer
to a moped
what the [__]
Jesus using every CC it's got oh my just
Vietnam things Jesus Christ but yeah
like uh yeah uh that's why I thought
driving I've I've
been in more close crashes in England
I think I think I'm I think I'm a
gentrified Asian he's gone a bad Asian
driver no coincidence
my first piece of evidence
all I'm saying is somehow I've never
come close to a crash in all my years of
driving in Thailand
yeah yeah
he put all of his skill points into
lockdown
you're re-rounded by a white couple in
the UK right yeah what I mean I mean
that was I mean that wasn't my fault
it's of course look that's that's what
the insurance company made like I said
okay and literally the guy the guy who
rear-ended me just said I just took my
eyes off the road for like five seconds
and uh that's how it always happens
when the eyes are on the road yeah
officer officer I just wasn't looking at
the road I'm sorry all right boys
if he crashed he didn't see it did he
really crash
oh my God have you guys ever been in any
uh crashes or Road accidents or anything
someone bumped our car once we were
parking Amber that was really weird I
was just kind of like [__] was that
when was this we were sitting in the
back of the car like 10 right uh yeah
we're parked and some car just bumped
into us and it was it wasn't like a big
bump but if you've ever had a car been
knocked even like a little knock really
[__] like shakes the car in a way
they're like whoa what the [__] that's
that was weird that was about it I I
haven't been in one but I have seen one
like happen right in front of me [__] it
was the place I lived in London do you
remember this the there's like a
junction there's always car crashes
happening there oh okay high-speed car
crashes it happened quite a lot yeah and
there's a few times where they crashed
um and went into like people's Gardens
and stuff yeah yeah yeah yeah I had one
too where like my the road where I grew
up in as well it's like a like a
cul-de-sac but then it comes out onto
like a T intersection of the main road
and before they have a roundabout there
now to because there were so many
accidents out there in there but I
remember when I was in like Middle
School I was like walking to the main
road to like go to the bus stop and
there was just this like cyclist just
coming up this hill really really slowly
oh and then just in front of me I was
looking at the cyclist and then there
was just a head-on oh and this this
cyclist probably went flying about like
20 meters okay I was like oh my God he
he's dead like he's straight up dead of
course tough Australian that he was just
got up and he was like I'm good he's
picked up his bike and just started
cycling again
this bike was still good the [__] and
the driver was like are you sure you're
okay like I would I would have called uh
Seoul Goodman bro I would have been yeah
oh ten times but in my head I was like
the only person who has the balls to get
into a head-on collision fly 30 meters
get up like nothing happened and then
continue cycling is someone that's
happened to him multiple times like this
because because I think like in
Australia at least in Sydney like
cyclists get into so many accidents
because it's like they have to drive on
the road yeah but they don't have like a
bicycle lane like they do in like Japan
like you know all the Southeast Asian
countries so they're just like in the
middle of the [__] road yeah and some
drivers are like well what the [__] I'm
gonna try and get around them and then
they either get it go into uh you know
uh the opposite traffic or they just
[__] bump the cyclist off their own
there should be enough room for both to
a little bit you think so but Jesus
cyclist they are in the [__] road
am I right Connor one quick story then
I'll get on the side okay so this is
like this weird experience had as a kid
so so
um it's not about car crashes but it's
about college yeah
um I was with my mom in a supermarket I
was like 10 years old
my mom's at the checkout and I I was
like ah can I just go and wait in the
car I don't know why I was like I was
like I want to go and play game boy or
something yeah and so I asked my mom can
I have the car keys and so I take the
car keys and I go to the parking lot and
I find uh the car and so I go to the car
and I put the keys in and turn it it
opens and I go in I'm sitting in there
and I'm playing game boy like 10 minutes
later I look around the car and I'm like
I don't think these seats look the same
as the one in my car
what the [__] and I look at the front
and I'm like that's that's not the front
of my mum's car either and I'm looking
at the seat again I'm like no this isn't
the car pattern at all I get out and I'm
like oh [__] this is the same car
but it's it's not our car and the key
worked on it
and apparently when I I looked it up and
it's it's all like the chance of this
happening is super low right yeah
because the key should only work on like
eight other cars in existence of that
model like it shouldn't work I actually
thought it was really weird that it
happened I was freaked out as a kid and
I told my mom my mum didn't believe me
and I was like I'm telling you I went
over this other car and I sat in there
for 10 minutes I played my Game Boy it
would have been real awkward like the
owner of the car came here yeah yeah
yeah well I was thinking maybe I should
make up someone came and beat me
but no it was uh yeah it was really
weird I remember that experience surreal
experience I did something almost
similar in Hawaii uh so you remember
when we went to Best Buy yeah and uh I
was like and someone give me the keys to
the truck yeah
um so you know I was I was kind of like
yeah you know a bit of space cadage like
let me let me just go in uh go in the
truck get my wallet so I can buy what I
need to buy at Best Buy so I go to the
truck
and I try like opening the doors it's
not opening it's not opening it just
doesn't open at all I'm like what's
what's going on is is the batteries dead
or something and I try like several
times and then I was like okay let me
try let me let me try actually just
putting the keys in I'm I'm at this
truck for about two minutes trying to
[__] squeeze this key in this Jeep
that we've rented out for a day it's
literally like two minutes ago we parked
in as well yeah yeah
after about two minutes of fiddling
fiddling around uh guy walks up to me
and goes what are you doing that's my
truck oh that's that's my Jeep and I
look up and I'm like I found myself at
the wrong Jeep I was trying to get I I
felt so bad because I was trying to get
in this Jeep for like a full-on three
four minutes uh and the the owner was
just like right on the other side
apparently just [__] watching me
trying to break into his truck oh my God
you're lucky didn't like [__] call
the police yeah holy [__] yeah you know
what makes the story even funnier our
jeep was parked I [__] you not two feet
from the entrance yeah yeah you were
literally the first car you would see as
you come out and somehow Khan did not
remember he was he was in Best Buy for a
total of two minutes and they're only
like three other cars
in the parking lot how the [__] did you
[__] that up I don't know I don't know
there was one there was I I looked up I
saw one big ass car uh in front of me
and I looked down and I was like I just
assumed my head oh that must be mine how
many big ass cars are could there
possibly be was it the exact same model
um it wasn't the exact same model but it
was the same it was the same color it
was the same color and it was also a G
oh my God it was close enough didn't it
was close enough to think that while we
were all standing around yeah
he's trying to Jack someone else's car
oh Jeep Waiting for God to come back we
were literally in this Best Buy for five
minutes
oh my God yeah so that's what I was
doing by the way wow yeah we wondered
where did you go yeah and he was like
yeah
okay okay all right sure you shouldn't
have the energy to explain it all right
I was [__] not good